hey everyone I'm James Murphy and you're
watching M coding where we try to take
credit for the achievements of the
compiler
today we're talking about what I
consider to be the most important C plus
compiler optimization
it helps your code go so fast it would
make Sonic the Hedgehog jealous
this optimization is so important that
all major compilers do it even in o0
mode
yeah common misconception o0 doesn't
turn off all optimizations just most of
them
for example just returning the sum of
two literal constants the compiler will
still just compute the answer even at
optimization level zero
this is called constant folding and it's
also important but not the most
important in my opinion
my vote goes to return value
optimization otherwise known as rvo and
or copyolition
here we have a simple struct s that just
contains an INT but it also prints to
standard out whenever you construct it
or copy it
in main let's just construct an S and
then print out the X data member
there we go construct s of 21 then the
answer is 21.
now what if instead of directly
constructing s we got it returned from a
function
functions are incredibly important
they're the building blocks of
abstractions that allowed the early
grates of programming languages to
ascend above the spaghetti code and
write code that other people can
actually understand
surely pushing the construction of s
inside a function won't slow down my
code otherwise there would always be
that incentive to devolve into our
Primal spaghetti nature
and indeed no change even at
optimization level zero
but in fact that's only because return
value optimization is still turned on
even at o0 so let's manually turn it off
we do that with this no elide
constructor's flag
and now we see
copy copy
not just one but two copies of our s
and if we had a more complex stack of
operations to put this object together
say make double value calls make value
now we see copy copy copy copy that's
four copies
two new copies every time we try to
return are struct
get rid of that flag and again they
disappear
now this is just a simple struct copying
it is just copying an INT but still four
copies to return it up two levels
and imagine if this is how it was for
all of your code strings and any other
objects containing real data would be
basically unusable forcing you to pass
pointers or references instead for
anything but trivial data that would be
annoying because pointers are a bit
trickier than just values and also
referencing everything through pointers
means paying for dereferencing all over
the place not to mention the Slowdown
from all the memory allocations needed
to get the memory underlying all those
pointers
but luckily that's not the C plus world
we live in in our world no copies
I hope that convinces you of what this
copy illusion can do for us in terms of
performance but now what exactly is it
doing where are all those copies coming
from in the first place and why are we
allowed to get rid of them
okay we've got four copies here where
are they all coming from
we call this function that calls this
function
that ultimately constructs the s
the memory for this temporary s is
allocated on the stack in the space made
available for the make value function at
the call site we need space for another
s the return value of that call
the return value is another temporary
its space is allocated on the stack made
available for the make double value
function
so basically we need to copy it from
here
to here
but we don't want to just throw away the
value we want to store it in this
variable s
so we need to make another copy from
this temporary into this little s
when we return our little s we make
another copy into the return value at
this call site
which we then copy again into this
little s
return value optimization and copulation
allow us to get rid of all of those
copies
but at this point something might feel a
little bit off
my Constructors had print statements in
them
so copy illusion isn't just making more
efficient assembly code it's changing
what my program does at runtime
if I made Hello World the compiler can't
just remove my print statements and say
oh yeah I made your code Faster by just
not printing hello world the print
statement was part of the program you
can't just remove it
by clearly copulation is removing my
print statements and that's because
return value optimization and copy
illusion are blessed by the language
these optimizations are so important
that in the standard that defines C plus
plus it specifically states that the
compiler is allowed and sometimes even
required to Omit calling a copy
Constructor when returning from a
function or when copying from a
temporary even if the copy Constructor
has side effects like printing setting a
global variable and so on
this is why you should not use your copy
Constructor to do anything besides copy
because it might not happen and it's why
you should use the copy Constructor to
make copies because if you write your
own copy function it can never be as
efficient as a copy Constructor because
the compiler may not be allowed to get
rid of calls to your copy function
so in short be careful but copulation is
awesome it lets us just return things by
value and still go fast
so in what situations is the compiler
actually allowed to do this
well this is C plus plus I mean if you
want the real correct answer it's
complicated you need to know all about
value categories PR values X values TL
values which I'm not going to cover here
but I can give you a rule of thumb
that's correct in a lot of situations
basically the compiler is allowed to do
copulation in a return statement or when
initializing from a temporary if the
types match so no conversion is required
and it can uniquely determine where the
memory should end up
for example where should the memory for
this s of X live well it's just
immediately constructed and returned so
instead of living in the stack space for
this function why don't we just put it
in the stack space for its caller this
is the situation that's technically
referred to as return value optimization
and where should the memory for the
temporary of this call go well it's
being immediately used to construct
another s so let's just put it in that
space
and where should the space for this s
live
well we always return that s so why
don't we just make it live at wherever
its color is and where should its caller
live well once again that temporary
value is just being used to initialize
another s so let's just put it in the
storage for that s
that s is never returned so its space
just lives in the space for Main
so when these are created all five of
these are directly created in the space
for this s in Main
on the other hand take a look at this
example where we can't get rid of the
copy
here we make two s's and then depending
on whether X is positive or negative
return one or the other of them
could we just put the memory for S1 at
the spot of where the return value goes
no we can't do that because we might
return S2
and just the same we can't put S2 there
because we might return S1
so the memory for this S1 and S2 has to
live here it can't be pushed up to the
caller
that means whichever one gets returned
it has to be copied into the caller's
memory
on the other hand here's an unexpected
situation where it can actually go the
other direction
this time we put the print inside a
function and pass a temporary
where should the memory for this
temporary in the caller go
just construct it directly into the
space for this function parameter
no copy
copulation can also happen when you
throw or catch an exception and inside
co-routines but I'm not going to talk
about those
as of C plus plus 17 in some instances
like this basic case of return value
optimization alighting the copy is not
even a choice anymore
it's not an optimization the compiler is
required to do it in these required
cases this not copy copy can happen even
when the copy Constructor is deleted
that's right you can return something
that's not even copyable like a unique
pointer or a mutex by value and this is
allowed because in C plus plus 17
technically the copy was not elided
technically due to this guaranteed
return value optimization it was never
there in the first place
as you can see in C plus plus 11 when I
try to return this s of X by value since
the copy Constructor is deleted it's not
allowed
but in C plus plus 17 due to guaranteed
copulation there was no copy the S
that's being returned is directly
constructed wherever it needs to go you
can even write what looks like a bunch
of manual copies and it doesn't matter
all of those copies are required to
never exist in the first place because
of this you would have what I might call
a language lawyer say that return value
optimization in 17 and onwards is
technically not copy illusion because
the standard defines that there was no
copy in the first place but colloquially
speaking no one's going to be confused
if you say that return value
optimization is copulation everybody
knows what you mean now until now I
haven't said anything about move
operations if you know what those are
and yes copy illusion Works in a similar
way for moves the compiler is allowed
and sometimes required to get rid of
moves but honestly me just listing out
more cases at this point probably isn't
going to do a lot of good so what I
recommend is to just open up compiler
Explorer and try a bunch of cases for
yourself
hopefully now you agree that return
value optimization and copulation are
awesome without them C plus plus would
be much much slower
thank you for sticking around to the end
that's all I've got if you especially
enjoy my content please do consider
becoming a patron or donor and don't
forget to subscribe
and of course don't forget to slap that
like button an odd number of times see
you next time